Gregg Alba is my name
Jordan Ross is my management your so off
of the screen I am I'm like totally in
this bridge hey buddy I was watching a
video on Jordans channel cinematics
movie channel it was one of his pitch
videos of Avengers and x-men Avengers
vs. x-men yeah and he actually had this
like great idea and even like great
listening of Cassidy gazlowe they get
this like wonderful idea I was like I
really see this work you know and then
it got me wanting to talk about a topic
that's kind of been on my mind which is
getting a new Wolverine he had a choice
in this video which i think is a great
choice because I know that Wolverine 3
is coming out and that'll be Hugh
Jackman's last performance as Wolverine
however something tells me that if
Marvel was like hey we want Wolverine in
the Avengers he would do I feel like
huge I'm going you know what I'm not
tired he's been a big proponent of like
getting these other properties in the
MCU before they got spider-man Hugh
Jackman was very vocal about hey we need
to get spider-man and Wolverine in the
event yes because there's such big parts
of it in the comic books and he's insane
lights dude you have to totally work it
out yeah he wants it to happen I'm
excited for Wolverine for him to like
have it as like Laster all because we
cube Jackman as Wolverine is gonna be
one of the hardest things to like
replace we already had heard of
Wolverine and then he comes out as
Wolverine and he has the all defining
Wolverine great people liked at him up
on his body
yeah Hugh Jackman Wolverine it's cool
because he had a lot working against him
yeah he wasn't short and he wasn't buff
if you watched the first x-men movie
he's kind of just a skinny guy yeah I
mean he's wrong yeah but he's not like
the fries man it's kind of funny too
because you watch them like you watch
movies but yeah it's like he must have
lost a lot of weight and gotten really
pale exactly so they're gonna get a new
Wolverine eventually would that be the
MCU working with Fox on the x-men series
or Fox just go many new Wolverine cuz
we're gonna need one here's what I think
if you do a new Wolverine I don't think
you should just continue the movie
and cast a new Wolverine yeah don't
think you should do that I feel like
we've had three what we're gonna have a
third Wolverine now for sure oranges
will brain is the worst out of the x-men
franchise yeah oh by far you then you
could say x-men 3 but or pause most
important but for sure without a doubt
number one worst movie
yeah the x-men franchise is origins well
and this is not debatable
the thing is though as one is they said
it would honor the comics a lot and then
there were complaints cuz there's
several types of origin hints and stuff
Wolverines passing some comics dedicated
to his origin yeah and yet it was still
very unsatisfying variant fulfilling in
a total boredom with the cartoon clause
oh dude watch and the theaters yeah may
my brother who were watching it and we
were just laughing that the entire movie
because it was so bad look how he gets
his awesome jacket and motorcycle from
an old guy yeah my point with that is I
think Wolverine deserves in another
origin yes like why not more than just a
quick montage of him fighting in wars
like seeing a Wolverine yeah movie would
be really cool taking time on your woman
like you I I wouldn't be against like
having its own separate origin trilogy
origin like spin officer I don't want to
do that with very long time you could do
like Wolverine origin trilogy like
whenever he first became Wolverine yeah
and then like as it goes on them
fighting in different wars meeting the
x-men like you could have a really cool
trilogy and there's other mutants you
can include I feel like that's what the
Wolverine showed us that you could do is
still get a cool mutant movie without
having it out shine Wolverine yeah
keeping it grounded okay I didn't read
the comics of x-men but I watch the
animated series on Fox growing up and
one of my favorite storylines in the
animated series and I don't know if it's
his acted to the comic or not but it was
the Lady Deathstrike story of how him
and Lady Deathstrike I forgot her actual
name but they were together before any
of them got there like
Weapon X yes so they have that whole
history there and x2 this is my hint at
something like not in the past
no which sucked because I remember when
they said Lady Deathstrike sent it and I
would have been like addicted to the
show yeah I was like oh yeah
and then there's none of that in there
you could have that in there and I feel
you feel like that if well they're gonna
get us a new Wolverine dude I'm totally
gung ho for a new reboot of the origin
tale because the origin movie sucked and
we deserve a good origin movie of
Wolverine why do we have to just go oh
we try that already it doesn't work eh
it'll help us reintroduce a new guy too
if we're gonna get a new person there
just throw them in there to be Hugh
Jackman's replacement yeah let's get a
new version of Wolverines as well and
you had a great choice like you said
it's gonna be a really difficult
character to recast because it's like
recasting Iron Man you know Robert
Downey jr. is Iron Man so when they
recast it inevitably or they could just
go with because I guess in the comics
Iron Man is now a female black teenager
so maybe they'll do that in the future
but either way it's like the girlfriend
precious yeah and with Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine that's someone that that's who
fancy as a Wolverine yeah so no matter
who they cast it's like some people are
gonna be upset but as I was thinking
about it for my pitch for Avengers vs.
x-men I went through a bunch of
different actors and the only one that I
could see and that I think I would enjoy
just as much as Hugh Jackman but could
bring his own spin to it it's Tom Hardy
he's shown that he can do action he's a
really good actor and he you know can
pull off the chops and everything he can
bump up like he didn't like Bane yeah
you can get more bronson he can get
really big and he's short you know he's
not a very tall I think he's like five
Niner zero right so yeah you could grunt
I think he would just be such a great
choice to play Wolverine yeah he
wouldn't he would be a great choice
especially in terms of like who's
already famous yeah but let's remember
when Hugh Jackman came out as Wolverine
no one knew who the [ __ ] you jack
he wasn't even the guy that was a cat
yeah I'm mi-2 was the guy who was good
yeah star see something funny but no
religion was actually highly considered
for the role oh that would have been
good that would have been interesting
watch another video although I don't
think Mel Gibson would have been as
committed or in yeah because like Hugh
Jackman committed to the physical yeah
it's true I just don't feel like they'll
give some would have been like you would
have been great just make great another
physical part yeah
I don't think I would have committed for
like 10 years we've heard Aaron Paul and
some weird yes we're the Aaron Paul it's
a weird choice yeah check out my closet
Taron Egerton I've heard him the
Kingsmen app if they went a younger
Wolverine I could see it but I just
picture wolverine a little more like not
old but i picture that guy for event
buff and and what i like to also see
from Wolverine is the more martial arts
driven wolverine yeah Datak wolverine
yeah cuz it's cool seeing the brutal
over scene like a show that but but you
just skilled martial arts fighter and he
can flip and [ __ ] yeah and he has like
amazing a jumping skills and yeah he has
more powers and he could smell and heal
fast yeah you know has touched on all
that a little bit more yeah I would like
to see them enhance the other aspects of
his powers that we don't really get was
one thing that I liked in x-men The Last
Stand granted like as a whole film not
the greatest yeah but one thing I liked
was that scene in the in the woods when
Wolverines fighting everyone yeah and
then he even has that moment where he
climbs up the tree of blood yeah but you
guys like that was on the steps more
Wolverine oh yeah I would also like to
see an enhancement of his powers and
they've kind of been making Wolverine a
little softer yeah I mean grand from his
cameo in Apocalypse very rough The
Wolverine he's the lead so they had to
like you know have a good balance of
[ __ ] and guy with a heart which is
Wolverine yeah but I want to see like a
nasty Wolverine yeah like a [ __ ] like
scary like a scary gritty not like a
good-looking sexy Hugh Jackman Wolverine
just like this guy is not appealing to
be around yeah and I feel like Tom Hardy
could pull Tom Hartigan Tom Hardy
wouldn't worry at all about being ugly
no no he's okay with that yeah he'd just
be grunting grunting yeah I would like
to see an ugly acrobatic fighting like
yeah give us some more extreme Wolverine
yeah reboot the origin tale for us yes
this new Wolverine Wolverine 3 is
supposed to wrap up Hugh Jackman's will
receive that's his old Wolverine man
Logan even got old Xavier and like so
this is supposed to be the end of his of
his story
so why not do a reboot let's get a
better origin movie in there please
because we want it and [ __ ] that whole
Deadpool [ __ ] you guys did although that
panned out
for us many years down yeah yeah just
the water good thing origins got us yeah
it's like a great Deadpool movie event I
would like to see like a trilogy or even
like I don't know like what if mmm Fox
decided to get into like what Marvel
with the MCU Disney Netflix yeah that
because the MCU has some great Netflix
shows out there
I love daredevil and I love this Jones
I'm excited for the upcoming Netflix
yeah I feel like Wolverine could totally
have it without me that would be a great
step for Fox ah yeah if they don't end
up teaming with the MCU I feel like
having your own Wolverine show that is
connected to them yes it'd be cool to
have like a great past show yeah but
then in the movies you have current you
haven't matured I like that that we
really need that would be there get out
the work guys
well in like we said I've heard that
Marvel and Fox that they've had some
discussions apparently that's the rumor
out there on the streets they've had
discussions about the possibility of
doing what Marvel did with Sony and
spider-man and whether it's I don't know
if they would recast or just cross the
universes come up with a another
dimension or something which would
explain you know all the differences or
whatever it could happen sooner than we
expected as much as I really like your
concept like a lot of people want that
Avengers in x-men yeah and a lot of
people want that and I really think that
if a lot of the ideas have heard yours
is by far the best one first so far of
having them crossed over
however there's other sites I mean
that's really okay with Fox's x-men
universe being separate yeah cuz it's
it's own Marvel world in a sense cuz
everyone is a [ __ ] mutant there's so
many characters it's a different world
if you know in the mutant world in the
Avengers world these heroes aren't as
heroic because there's a lot more people
walking on the streets with superpowers
yeah I know like agents of shield kind
of covers that a little bit more about
the word yeah so I feel like that with
the egg with the x-men world they do
have a Cinematic Universe here that they
get totally capital yeah yeah doing a
new Wolverine I think a show be a great
way to cuz it's a it's a different
format it's different origins so this is
a great way to reintroduce a new face
cuz let's let's face it when we get a
new over rings gonna be a lot of
backlash yeah whoever the [ __ ] is gasps
whoever even if it's not party people
are gonna be pissed until them actual
move
comes out yeah they say he didn't like
that with a big con book here Batman
or with banana Batman comes out and like
he's one of the cheesie's people like
yeah he's like the best part of the
movie yeah exactly
Heath Ledger's Joker yeah but there's a
lot of casting short like even Robert
Downey jr. as Iron Man a lot of people
didn't like that at first because it's
like oh yeah that guy that did some
movies in the 80s and just got out of
rehab but then when it came out now no
one can picture anyone else playing iron
even Hugh Jackman as Wolverine yeah no
people heard about who they were casting
this was before the internet was the
[ __ ] internet but yeah when they
heard about like Hugh Jackman was cast
people were really like disappointed
with it and Bryan's defending apocalypse
said like people were pissed at me when
I cast you know a six-foot actor to play
Wolverine with look what happened there
yeah I mean it wasn't the same response
to the positives that did remind me of
that time when people were like why is
this guy Wolverine it worked out great
and I feel like box and you know like
don't do try to rush anything here yeah
don't DC is doing well yeah yeah be like
we gotta hurry and catch up Marvel is
doing so well because they took their
time yeah and they may have done it
first but just because they're way ahead
doesn't he's not a cop it's not a race
it's not a competition yeah I just don't
get it
it's just not your time like you're two
separate companies separate things just
like eventually down the road you'll
make it you'll make a movie that makes
just as much money yeah yeah as long as
you take your time and go for quality
over quantity you don't throw down many
new characters in as possible I don't
like how much studios act like um movie
like oh if we don't catch up people are
gonna do not like us forget about us
that's not the case no we're here stay
yeah yeah well the thing I love about
Marvel they do these big event films but
then they do these smaller more intimate
ones like ant-man yeah that's a very
intimate superhero movie the world isn't
in danger you know about this one guy
and his daughter has fun yeah and it's
fun Doctor Strange looks kind of like
that like Black Panther it looks like
it's gonna be specifically in Wakanda so
you know they do these more intimate
films and they work they're fun because
they take their time they'll have little
cameos throughout them and they build up
to the big movies yeah
DC just jumped right in with big move
there's just so many characters to last
the people who run the the comic book
movie universe yeah all these films from
x-men to the all MCU to the DC EU
there's enough films to last enough
characters alone to last that till these
guys [ __ ] die yeah and then they can
do more new characters certainly Marvel
and I was like their slate mapped out
until like 2030 already
that's not surprised now because they
are probably only one reveal for them
not like the next few years now but
probably by the time they reveal it
they'll have it through like 2015 yeah
exactly so many characters is never
gonna happen
have you ever looked at like a [ __ ]
slate like just a list of all the
character yeah like they'll do Squirrel
Girl eventually I'm sure like it's the
Marvel Universe like you break down the
Marvel Universe yeah I got the
spider-man you know yeah every every
character has a universe yeah all their
own individual enemies in in like
sidekicks and exactly like all this
stuff it's exciting it's exciting pretty
excited yeah I hope they do Wolverine a
lot of people are getting superhero
fatigue but it's like huh
cuz as long as they're done right it
won't get old like I don't like how
Marvel does it they make sure they do it
right it's just a John can go on forever
it's like saying like I'm sick of all
these colonies coming out that's like
yeah always just a genre superhero
movies a job yeah you could be sick of
like bad comedies or bad superhero
movies but yeah hey you're sick of just
the genres yeah a little ridiculous as a
fun talk oh well you go who do you think
would be a great Wolverine yeah comment
below
anyway dudes and dudettes and men and
women and children and nuns if you're
new to the channel subscribe to the
subscription services $20.99 a month to
get unlimited access to some of the
videos on here $25.99 a month to get
even more access
that's a premium membership no Jordan
his channels free brand-new its
cinematic it's all movie talk it's great
IQ this guy had clearly he's a movie
buff you're a movie buff you're gonna
like his channel yeah Jake from
superheroes to silent there are
superhero movies to silent movies
everything to movies that didn't even
get released yes I actually have a top
ten movies that were never released list
that I'm gonna do really long so yeah
he's right oh wow yeah